التأمين على السفر صحيح ، أنا دائمًا الشخص الذي ينقر هذا النوع من النقرات لا لأنني لا أريد إنفاق الأموال الإضافية ولكن هل هو جائحة مغطى في هذا إذا اشتريناه جيدًا في سياسات تأمين السفر القياسية التي تغطي معظم العناصر ولكن ليس كل السياسات المتعلقة بالسفر تغطية الأوبئة مثل فيروس كورونا ، لذا فأنت بحاجة إلى قراءة التفاصيل الدقيقة إذا كنت ستشتري إلغاء الرحلة أو تأمين انقطاع الرحلة ، لكن الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني أن أوصي به للعائلات هو أن يبحث الصيف عن شيء يسمى الإلغاء لأي سبب من أسباب التأمين ، إنه حوالي 40 ٪ أكثر من تأمين السفر القياسي ، ولكن كما يقول ، يمكنك التراجع أو الإلغاء لأي سبب ، خاصة الآن بعد أن كانت هناك شواطئ تقترب من الزيادات التي تحدث في ولايات مختلفة ، ماذا عن استرداد أموالك ، أنت تعلم أنني قد حدث هذا مع فندق لن يعيدوني أموالي ، لقد قالوا فقط ، يمكنك استخدامه في العامين المقبلين وأنا لا أعرف ما إذا كنت أريد السفر في العامين المقبلين
تتصل بشركة بطاقة الائتمان الخاصة بك وتفعل
ما يسمى برد المبالغ المدفوعة ، كما تعلم
للأسف ، لا تقدم بطاقات الائتمان
سوى القليل من الحماية أو لا توفر حماية على الإطلاق لبطاقات الائتمان
الموجودة في محفظتك عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالرحلة ، فهناك بعض
بطاقات Lyne عالية الدولار مثل American
Express  البطاقة البلاتينية التي تغطي ما يصل إلى
عشرة آلاف دولار لكل شخص أو
عشرين ألف دولار لكل بطاقة ولكن
الكثير منها لا تغطي Lynne ببساطة
الأوبئة مثل فيروس كورونا ، لذلك
كنت أتصل بشركة بطاقتي الائتمانية
قبل الاعتماد عليها لحماية الرحلة ما
يحدث  إذا حجزت شيئًا مثل
Airbnb والذي أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس
يفعلونه لأنهم ليسوا مرتاحين جدًا
في الفنادق ، ولكن نعم بالتأكيد ، فإن Airbnb قد
طرح شيئًا يسمى
الظروف المخففة حيث يقوم مجلس المراجعة
بمراجعة الأوبئة وهذا يضع
سياسة لكن  عقدك هو في
النهاية بينك وبين المضيف الذي
قمت بتعيينه مع معظم hotz كانت
مرنة جدًا ولكن على موقع Airbnb x '
spe  تنص بشكل خاص على أنه إذا قمت
بحجز الرحلة قبل 14 مارس ،
فيمكنك الإلغاء لأي سبب من الأسباب حتى
31 يوليو ، ولكن إذا حجزت الرحلة بعد
14 مارس ، يمكنك الإلغاء حتى
31 يوليو ولكن ليس لأسباب متعلقة بـ kovat 19 ،
لذا اتصل في النهاية
بمضيفك اقرأ النسخة المطبوعة  من العقد
لأن هذا ما سيحدث